start with my take on razzle huh newt a  classic Moroccan spice blend in a dry  pan toast cinnamon cloves coriander  fenugreek and fennel seeds then add  mustard seeds and cumin when the seeds  start to pop they're ready add paprika  and grind into a fine powder for the  hummus peel and chop butternut squash  put on a baking tray and add garlic  simply bashed and chopped ginger  drizzle with olive all season and  sprinkle over the spice mix  then roast in a hot oven for half an  hour inches soft  allow to cool and place in a blender add  tahini a nutty paste made from sesame  seeds cup chickpeas a dash of lemon  juice and a drizzle of olive oil  blitz into a luxurious and creamy and  textured spices toasted for maximum  flavor amazing roasted squash hummus  coat white bait in the spicy flour mix  then fry add cube potatoes chicken stock  and seasoned